Gwen Stefani and her man Blake Shelton
cutting white Christmas beat in their
future
well it seems he knows somebody who can
make that happen as of lauren zima found
out lake what are you getting your
special lady for christmas you know I
like you but not enough to tell you that
but I would like to point out that Kelly
is so rich she is bringing in a snow
machine to California for two weeks just
so that our kids have snow Christmas
will come to me so Blake has mastered
the art of deflecting and redirecting
but we're thinking he's already giving
win a pretty sweet gift appearing
alongside her for their Christmas duet
even though he's not a fan of filming
music videos Merry Christmas everybody
we were with his wild trio of boys
coaches last night for part one of the
season 15 finale noticeably absent from
the carpet Adam he's the only one
without a contestant in the Final Four
no Adam how do we fall my god everyone's
rubbing it in it's so bad and like
badass it's awesome what it is no team
but they did choose him as their coach
and you know he's a loser
I was trying to think of the past
Christmas gifts that Adam has given me I
think I'm gonna give him the exact same
thing this year which is a big bowl of
error
[Laughter]
you